zugeschaltet ist uns jetzt virologe
klaus stöhr hersteller wie sind diese
zahlen denn nun tatsächlich
einzuschätzen die oft wie
digitalisierungs rate ist ein bisschen
widersprüchlich weil viele patienten
eben mit corona eingeliefert werden aber
nicht wegen corona und trotzdem zählen
sie in die statistik mit rein ja ja die
situation hat sich so entwickelt wie man
es vorher gedacht hatten ihre scheren
tut sich auch zwischen der anzahl der
gefundenen infektionen viele sehr viele
asymptomatisch oder mild uns dem was wir
auf den intensivstationen in den
krankenhäusern sehen dass eine für die
eine schere verläuft steil nach oben und
der an geschenke horizontal
beziehungsweise nach unten und da muss
man reagieren die ideen sie auch auf
ihren karten die identität alle tifosi
müssen sich glauben von neue farben
einfallen lassen oder vielleicht die
farben anpassen weil in der zukunft in
den nächsten zwei bis drei wochen die
instanzen weiter steigen werden aber die
hospital regierungsrat und auch die
belegung mit intensivstation mit aller
wahrscheinlichkeit sich stabilisieren
wird dann sehen wir ja auch in unseren
nachbarländern da wo gute studien auf
kollegen aus den usa ist ein gutes
studio nochmal 50 prozent geringerer
wahrscheinlichkeit ins krankenhaus
bekommen
bevor bleiben auf die intensivstation zu
kommen das wird nicht auch in
deutschland
weiterentwickeln und die kritische
infrastruktur die kollegen bei der
feuerwehrwache wirtschaft energie die
haben sich ja schon seit anfang der
pandemie mit ihren pandemieplänen darauf
eingestellt heute hat der verband sei
wasser in energie wirtschaft gesagt auch
bei ihnen ist die lage relativ entspannt
wir haben natürlich auch erkrankungen
aber kommen mit der fertigung gut
zurecht wir müssen uns also langsam an
die realität gewöhnen und die maßnahmen
anpacken nun war er regionaldirektor
hans klug dass in sechs bis acht wochen
die hälfte der europäer mit omikron
infiziert sein könnte was halten sie von
dieser berechnung könnte das tatsächlich
zutreffen ich habe die berechnungen die
zahl nicht gesehen natürlich sehr schwer
europas und der größe der großregion 800
millionen menschen und die trends laufen
unterschied nicht in österreich auch
deutschland bei der tief geringe
intelligenzen bank reichen gallien
portugal spanien england schweiz die
haben alle instanzen bei vier fünf sechs
mal höher und die laufen zum teil auch
in die andere richtung gescher abfallend
von einem großen berg die meisten
anderen ansteigen auch schweden also
aber was er was einheitlich sicherlich
für alle länder gilt ist das nikon eine
sehr sehr große anzahl von fällen
verursacht aber so wie die zahlen das
jahr zeigen und die fakten in der
großteil milde und asymptomatischen
fälle und das wird nicht auch bei uns so
weiter durchsetzen die inzidenz von 800
denke ich mir wird realistisch sei in
deutschland aber dann wird man sich
gewöhnen müssen so lange wie die
krankenhäuser und die in der die station
nur belegten wie
geht das eigentlich alles in die
richtung zum ende der pandemie die
spanische regierung will ja corona
aufgrund der omicron ausbreitung sogar
als krippe einstufen was halten sie
davon
ja die in der solchen bekämpfung passt
man die maßnahmen der situation an und
wenn eine erkrankung so verläuft wie zb
die schon existierenden wir in
englischen krone viren zirkulieren ja
schon vier viren auch corona jahrzehnten
jahrhunderten die verursachende 10 bis
30 prozent der atemwegserkrankung da hat
meine quarantäne auch überlegt da ist
ein impfstoff noch nicht mal ökonomisch
belastbar zu entwickeln also da muss man
sich dann mit maßnahmen anpacken dann
sind wir noch nicht angelangt mit der
bande wie jetzt aber auf dem schritt auf
dem weg dahin muss man schritte der
verantwortung unternehmen mann hatte in
südafrika schon die kontakt
beschränkungen und kontakte verfolgung
waren aufgehoben deutschland nun als
einziges der die geimpften nicht mehr in
die waren wenig geschickt wenn wir
kontakt haben und andere länder die
strategische denken legen zumindest
ideen auf den tisch welche schritte die
unternehmen wollen wenn sich die
situation in die richtung entwickelt
bieber das
kloster die einschätzung des virologen
ganz herzlichen dank dafür und bei uns
im studio ist alexander kissler ist
journalist von der neuen zürcher zeitung
das ganze hat natürlich eine politische
dimension auch wie ist da die an die
zahlen geben ja verschiedene botschaften
aus zum einen sind wir natürlich noch in
der pandemie es wäre unvernünftig jetzt
alle maßnahmen aufzuheben die frage die
sich allerdings mit täglich größerer
politischer dringlichkeit stellt ist
haben wir die richtigen maßnahmen
schießen wir nicht über das ziel hinaus
gutes beispiel ist eben die
hospitalisierung rate sie wurde mitte
november noch von der bund länder
konferenz als maßgebende größe angegeben
ab 3 sollten strenge maßnahmen greifen
das sind wir ganz knapp über 3 in vielen
bundesländern unterhalb von 3 zwischen
2,0 und 2,5 und trotzdem halten wir nach
wie vor an maßnahmen fest die erst
eigentlich ab eine hospitalisierung rate
von 6 vorgesehen werden das heißt wir
legen in deutschland großen wert darauf
ein so genanntes regiment der angst
wiesmann nennen möchte fortzusetzen
jetzt laufen gefahr uns in einen
permanenten
ausnahmezustand zu gewöhnen indem wir
immer die szenarien herauspicken oder
die viele politiker die zehn jahre
heraus picken die möglichst strenge
maßnahmen legitimieren wir sind
mittlerweile fast weltweit spitze was
die strenge der regel angeht auch was
die regelungsdichte angeht und
gleichzeitig sind wir in gefahr da durch
das zu verlieren was uns als
gesellschaft auszeichnen dass wir offen
diskutieren dass wir massnahmen anpassen
und das war eben nicht weiter die
gesellschaft spalten und die
gesellschaft wird sich eben weiter
spalten wenn auf gedeih und verderb von
maßgeblichen politischen kräften immer
nur in einer richtung gedacht wir müssen
dieses diese gewöhnung einen
ausnahmezustand und das regiment der
angst müssen wir überwinden wir müssen
auch die hoffnungssignale die es gibt
aufnehmen ohne unvernünftig zu werden
wir haben gestern darüber berichtet dass
ungeimpfte abgeordnete nicht mehr im
bundestag im plenarsaal platz nehmen
dürfen sondern auf die tribüne verbannt
werden von dort aus ihre reden halten
müssen was halten sie davon also das
verstehe ich überhaupt nicht das
verstehe überhaupt nicht wer eine maske
trägt das wissen wir nun ist
einigermaßen wenn er sie richtig trägt
einigermaßen geschützt zusätzlich kann
man wenn man der maske nicht glaubt noch
einen tagesaktuellen test machen und
sehr viele sind momentan freiwillig
geimpft das heißt ist ein erheblicher
eingriff in die dass die ausübung des
freien mandats eigentlichen ich meine
wir haben noch keine impfpflicht wir
haben mitglieder frei gewählte
parlamentarier die das volk in seiner
gesamtheit vertreten die nur
eingeschränkt teilnehmen können gestern
wurden teilweise habe ich gehört
abgeordnete davon abgehalten in
ausschüssen mitzuarbeiten weil es eben
diese neuen regeln nicht erfüllt hatten
also das finde ich sehr sehr und
souverän man muss wirklich sagen können
solange es noch keine impfpflicht gibt
muss als schutz in innenräumen abstand
maske tagesaktueller test ausreichend
und letzten endes ist es ja auch ein
arbeitsplatz und es gibt für die
parlamentarier es gibt ja wenig
arbeitsplätze in deutschland denen zweig
plus vorgeschrieben und die folge wäre
aber das ja die ungeimpften dann ihren
status beziehungsweise alle ihren
impfstatus offenlegen müssten exakt
genau das wäre dann das wäre eine
weitere nebenfolge die man auch kritisch
sehen kann ich finde es ganz wichtig in
diesen zeichen in diesen zeiten weniger
zeichen der hoffnungslosigkeit als der
hoffnung zu setzen und weniger zeichen
der spaltung als der verbindung der
gemeinsamkeit und wenn ich mir gestern
die bundestagsdebatte anhöre woher
scholz stolz war dass deutschland die
weitreichendsten kontakt beschränkungen
europas hat da kann ich sagen das ist
doch sechs mal ein formales kriterium
wie sie in anderen ländern mit deutlich
weniger kontakt beschränkungen die auch
genauso gut oder sogar besser durch die
krise gekommen sind es wurde jetzt
bekannt die untersuchung vom economist
dass schweden im jahr 2021 die geringste
über sterblichkeit in deutschland gehabt
hat die schweiz zum beispiel haben wir
gerade im großen vergleich in der nz wie
ein mittelweg gefahren ist zwischen
liberalität und strenge hat ungefähr die
gleiche anzahl an todesopfern pro 100000
einwohner also es gibt alternativen
würde mich interessieren sie sind
korrespondent der neuen zürcher zeitung
wie es leben die stimmung in der schweiz
in der schweiz ist es ein großer vorteil
dass man da natürlich eine eine
abstimmung hatte eine volksabstimmung
hatte die zur befriedung der situation
beigetragen hat der hat die möglichkeit
dort nicht nur an wahlen seien auch
plebisziten die stimmung abzugeben es
gibt zwar einen einlass beschränkungen
großteils für innenräume zweig aber es
ist keine impfpflicht debatte keine
impfpflicht debatte und es gibt vor
allem nicht diese stigmatisierung die
wir in deutschland haben also es ist
nicht so dass also sehr stark moralisch
sondern es wird viel stärker pragmatisch
argumentiert natürlich gibt es auch
menschen die aus prinzipiellen
erwägungen
die das impfen ablehnen aber sie wenn du
nicht wohin habe und abgestellte bei uns
und ich glaube in diesem punkt kann man
sagen bitte etwas mehr schweiz wagen